jordan in utah you're on the bench
pressure go for jordan
hi ben thanks for taking my call so i
had a question for you again about
systemic racism
um so i had this experience as a
missionary in connecticut
on the drive between west hartford to
hartford where
everyone went from it's actually
hartford west hartford where everyone
from
usually poor not white and then two
blocks later like
like mini mansions everywhere everyone's
white
um i feel like left has done a really
good job
i'm kind of taking this kind of general
feeling of like oh look there's
you know people are poor and
no one's white over there and then two
blocks later like everyone's white
everyone's rich they've done a really
good job of kind of taking that
that message and turning it into into
systemic racism
right yes i was wondering if you thought
there was anything
conservatives could do as far as
messaging
to to to kind of still address the
problem but
but doing it in a conservative way we're
like sure so i think it's free
yeah so jordan i think that there's a
category error that has been
actively promulgated by the media and by
the political left and you mentioned the
category error here
and that is there are two cross-cutting
distinctions that we've mentioned in
this conversation already the
cross-cutting distinction between poor
and rich
and the cross-cutting distinction
between black and white one of these
right is not the cause right so so what
the left has done is they've said
that the distinctions are essentially
the same they've conflated the two poor
equals black rich equals white right
this is something that joe biden himself
has said
right joe biden gaffed a couple months
ago and he said
you know there's a difference between
being rich and being black
right which is which is an incredible
statement there are lots of rich black
people in america
and there are lots of poor white people
in america yeah so what so
because black people in the united
states are disproportionately poorer
than
white people in the united states
although asian people in the united
states are disproportionately richer
than either one of those groups by the
way
because people conflate the
cross-cutting distinctions between they
say because they basically argue that
poor equals black and rich equals white
first of all that's kind of racist
because it ain't true but two it's
actually yeah it's ignoring the real
problem which is how do we get poor
people to be richer
right the question is not did those rich
people steal the money from the poor
people because they didn't
the question and the question is no are
there legal structures in place that
keep the poor people poor
because there aren't the real question
is and and the question isn't even what
happened in history
to make certain areas lower income
versus certain areas
higher income the question is what can
we do today to make poor people richer
and this is why you've seen it it's
really fascinating you've seen
a gap open up or at least there was a
gap until very recently between sort of
the bernie sanders wing of the party the
sort of socialist wing of the democratic
party
and the racial justice warrior wing of
the democratic party because bernie
sounds kind of more like a a republican
when he suggests that what we're really
talking about is the distinction between
rich and poor
right his solutions are wrong but he
says what we're really talking about is
a class issue here
and then there are democrats who say
it's not really a class issue to race
race issue but bernie is right that it's
more of a class issue right it is more
about like poor versus rich
and then the question becomes what
decisions can we incentivize in people's
lives
so that poor areas become richer what
can we do to gentrify those areas
and one of the things that you will see
from members of the political left is an
objection
to many of the steps that need to be
taken in order to make it easier for
poor people to become rich so this is
what you see with the
insane stuff from the national museum of
african american history and culture
where they say that punctuality
cause and effect that the scientific
method these are white people things
no those are those are ways that you get
successful right being a
being a diligent person is how you
become successful in the united states
regardless of your race
it's why when you see the left saying we
need to get rid of the police you think
to yourself okay that is making it worse
for poor people
regardless of race it's making it
significant 81 percent of black
americans say they want at least the
same number of police in their
neighborhoods or more police in their
neighborhoods
so the so it i think the human beings
have an innate tendency to make
distinctions based on visible
differences like differences between
race
but the actual visible differences that
should matter are the differences
between
for example rich and poor how many cops
are on the streets what are the housing
conditions like how do we get more
businesses into these neighborhoods what
are the crime rates
like right if you want to if you want to
make it so that poorer areas in hartford
are more like richer areas then how do
you make it so that poorer areas are
more like richer areas
rather than assuming that the white
people are keeping the black people down
or that some sort of de facto
segregation is the actual rationale here
instead of individual decision making
that can actually be cured you can't
you can't really cure the nature of
human sin what you can do is incentivize
people to make good decisions
and make it easier for them them to make
good decisions by vitiating
the obstacles to cause and effect what
crime does for example
is it vitiates what what crime does is
it it creates an obstacle to cause an
effect
right you're working hard you're doing
your best and you can't get any
customers to come in your store because
they're afraid they're gonna get robbed
right you're doing what you can and the
system has not provided protection for
your property
so what do we need to do we need to
provide protection for your property so
that cause and effect are now
effectuated
so is there a message republicans should
be pushing because
a lot of it's just like you know
democrats are wrong but i feel like
democrats are winning the messaging on
this well
i think democrats are wanting the
messaging mainly because
most americans see disproportionate
differences between groups
and they immediately assume that that is
due to inequity
that it is due to some sort of
discrimination so the the conflation
between disparity and discrimination
is a very easy one it's an easy mental
trick to play but the truth is that
there are disparities between every
group right as i mentioned earlier
asian americans have a much higher
household income than white americans
that doesn't mean that asian americans
are discriminating against white
americans
or that the system is built to benefit
asian americans it means that
there are many areas of the united
states where people individually need to
make better decisions where governments
need to make better decisions about how
to
incentivize good decision-making and
prevent crime and
yes put criminals in jail and that would
be a good thing
the same leftists who are who are
claiming that we need better
opportunities in poor minority
neighborhoods are opposing
gentrification
gentrification is bringing more money
into those communities you can't have it
both ways
yeah cool jordan really appreciate the
call
and thanks for the missionary work
that's obviously a very very good thing
steve in chicago you're on the venture
go for it steve
hey ben uh several years ago you were
doing a live show in seattle with black
lives matter activists it's a it's a
popular youtube clip
when asked about whether racism is a
driving factor in income inequality you
responded
because it has nothing to do with race
and everything to do with culture
some of your fellow panelists initially
started laughing but
you continued with your response and
they had no answer
so i wanted to ask you could you define
culture
what elements of culture in the black
community are driving income inequality
and is it possible to discuss culture
honestly
without being branded racist since race
and culture are so deeply interrelated
so first of all i don't think that race
and culture have to be interrelated nor
nor should they be i mean i wouldn't say
that it is quote unquote black culture
to
not value education there are plenty of
black americans who value education
extraordinarily
highly i think that there's there are
certain pathologies that exist
in poor communities black or white that
are common across
those communities now they may not exist
in the same proportions in those
communities
but that has nothing to do with race and
everything to do with culture right
there they're areas of white appalachia
where education is not valid
particularly highly jd vance talks about
this
in in hillbilly elegy the the
pathologies of poverty that exist
cross-racially are the same and then
it's just a question of of how often
they exist
in particular communities regardless of
race so pathologies of poverty include
not valid
valuing education enough such that your
kids are not spending a lot of time
on homework or not having fathers in the
home such that you have two parents who
are available to help read with your
kids
pathologies of poverty exist high
include high
crime include again lack of fathers in
the home means that very often young men
tend to congregate in gangs right those
are pathologies of poverty
right all those pathologies are not
unique to the black community they may
exist disproportionately in particular
black communities but that doesn't mean
that that's because of the race
the bottom line is that the recipe for
success is the same for everyone in the
united states
you make responsible decisions you don't
have babies out of wedlock you finish
high school
if you go to college try to major in in
something where you're actually gonna
make money on the other end like for
example you'll see people cite
statistics that black college graduates
don't earn as much as white college
graduates
well that doesn't adjust for major if
you major in in
a soft study a liberal arts study you're
not gonna make as much money as if you
major in stem
which is why white college graduates
earn less than asian american college
graduates for example
right they're just decisions and so what
i said in that clip and it's right
obviously which is why you see the the
people who i'm talking to one is a
member of the local naacp
one's member of the seattle stranger
right you see these people go from
laughing to being kind of chastened
a little bit in the clip is it is not
arguable
that pathologies of poverty like single
motherhood have nothing to do with race
when the single motherhood rate in the
black community went from 20 to 1960
to well over 70 today that is going to
have some significant downstream effect
when the high school dropout rate
differential between high school black
students
and high school white students is
significant that's going to have
significant downstream effect
what does that have to do with race the
answer is it doesn't have anything to do
with race
okay so i think the way to discuss it is
to point out over and over and over
again
that this is not a racial distinction
this is a this is a distinction between
decisions that individuals
make and can make and our job in terms
of public policy is to incentivize
people to make the right decisions
not to incentivize them to make the
wrong decisions by for example
compensating them for making the wrong
decisions which is what welfare policy
did
in the 1960s and helped exacerbate the
problems of single motherhood
in black communities by the way as well
as white communities the single
motherhood rate in the white community
was five percent
in 1960 today it's well in excess of 40
well ben thank you for that i mean i
think the thing that is a little
frustrating
when i hear democrats talking is that
they refuse to address the culture issue
whatsoever they they immediately want to
go to social programs and not discuss
culture and i just think culture is such
an important element
that does drive income inequality i'm
just surprised they won't do it
i mean all we mean by culture when we
say culture is just decisions made by
people
and when we say culture it means like a
disproportionate number of bad decisions
or good decisions made by a particular
group of people
and again that is not that's why i'm not
going to say it's quote unquote black
culture on education
that that black people don't care about
education that's not true it depends on
which areas you're talking about so
again that has nothing to do
with race and saying that things have
nothing to do with race is a pretty good
way of explaining that things have
nothing to do with race
it's hard to be branded a racist when
you keep saying over and over things
have nothing to do with raise that don't
have to do with raise
really appreciate the call alrighty in
just a second we'll take more of your
calls at 855-236-3228